A lot of people seem to think that
web apps can never compete with
native mobile apps for reliability,
speed and user engagement.
And it’s hard to build
a business case for them.
You know what?
They used to be right.
But two things have changed.
First, it turns out that most people
buy most of their apps when they
get their phone or shortly after.
Worse, most people install a few
common apps and call it a day.
That makes it harder for
developers to compete.
But people still keep using the web.
And a few new technologies let you
offer key features customers want,
from native apps.
We call these progressive web apps.
Progressive web apps are web apps
that took all the right vitamins.
They are experiences that combined the
best of the web and the best of apps.
They give users the kind of reliable,
fast, and engaging experience that
they've come to expect from native
apps that delivered through the web.